all
right again I thought I I do want to
teach my Desi this form I do want my son
to learn it my youngest son and uh I
thought you would benefit as somebody
that maybe doesn't know the form or is
relearning
it based on how I teach it I thought
you'd benefit from watching how I teach
my son
okay so we're not just going to do the
form like you see on all those other
videos I shared and you just learn it
cuz you're never going to get it get it
that way okay um we have to go deeper I
would never just show the form to people
in my own school let alone my son and go
go okay so again in the set one weapon
is
bladed and common to bladed weapons is
this tactic which Cally
in in my knif fighting
training we called it defang
defanging the
snake okay and what it is is it's must
much less costly and thereby risky to
stab
something that is closer to you than
closing
to stab something okay so n out of 10
times it means cutting the
arm of the weapon that is trying to hit
you as opposed to for example trying to
cut the person's
torso so in an abstract way here is my
torso here is my adversary's
torso it is much riskier here for me to
close the distance towards this person
and try to stab the head the neck the
rib cage Etc it is less risky for me to
stab something that is in the middle of
us too okay so for
example uh in this
case the
adversary has the
Joe and when they put that weapon as in
uh the previous move this arm is closer
to me as the bulken
person and it is much easier for me to
try to cut that arm that is sticking
somewhere out here in the middle of the
fight then to come back and try to cut
their head or their neck or something
like that because the closer I get to
here more Arsenal is available to my
opponent such as the rear end of the Joe
can turn it on
me but also personal weapons kicks hands
so they can grapple they can grab my
weapon they can punch and kick me it is
just much safer to not deal with the
additional Arsenal and just t attack the
thing that is sticking out so that is
defanging the snake so in the moves
where we're at the
sword is attacking the lead arm of the
Joe
okay when I do however there's two
things that I'm going to try to combine
because my goal is stay as way away as
much as possible from all those other
weapons near their torso so what I'm
going to try to do is combine one to two
things here or use one to two things one
I'm going to try to move the X closer to
me this is the front arm of the
Joe and if necessary I will move myself
towards the X but I will not move myself
any further towards the spine as is
necessary to cut the X okay so to
understand where we're at what I mean
here is like I'm going to try to move
what I'm trying to cut towards me so I
don't have to get closer to here and if
necessary I will move myself towards the
X but no more that would put me at risk
by moving me closer okay so if we're
here you just come over here
Tristan and he has that weapon up in my
face there when I step back I'm going to
move him towards me that moved the X
towards me okay and whatever I didn't
get right in my movement so whatever I
didn't get I'll move myself but I won't
move myself any closer
that I start having the rear end of the
Joe come up at me or a headbutt or a
kick okay and I might have to combine
these two so as he comes up and I come
here who there was a combination but if
I can hit that weapon boom as I bring
him way in then that's what I want to be
I don't want to get used to I'm always
going to do sugii such that if you hit
the person's back arm you went wait too
far you over penetrate
okay so in that
portion of this move I would like to
focus in on this
part what brings the X close to me okay
that is an iy
adhesion
okay and we know from I that it is a
communion of two forces
there's two forces minimum that have to
become one the one force is created by
ukas Joe going up towards the face it
has an upward
energy the other force is created by the
sword person doing the otos it has a
downward energy okay
and here those downward energy and
upward energy are neutralized those two
y energies are neutralize and they and
the sword person moves the ax closer to
them so that they don't have to over
penetrate so they don't near the Torso
area of the adversary
okay when you do
this as we mentioned in kihon waza so go
back to kihon waza and many of you tried
kihon waza with the internal aspects and
you're realizing I'm freaking the hell
out of my ukas and they do this or they
do that or they do that right um and as
I mentioned many times before one of the
things that they do is they just try to
free their center from the
adhesion in Gaza I say just go to the
next adhesion point in Kaza I say no
that's bad in ki because UK is supposed
to let their tanden be seized and spiral
rotated by
Naga cha Sensei sets are forms but they
are not Kona that is very important
there is built in a counter so there's
an attack and a counter and it is uh not
like at all like uh Kon waza because
there's no counter in kihon waza okay so
you have to be able you're going to be
attacked and then the UK has to counter
and here's the thing that counter
actually happens through the I adhesion
that part is very difficult for the
scaredy cat UK who's going to be more
afraid in weapons because the weapons
hurt as we already demonstrated they
hurt more than the hands hurt especially
when we controlling for our environment
for kionga okay so let me set up this
problem more he comes
out and we have his upward energy and I
have downward energy and I neutralize
the downward don't lose it dude I
neutralize the upward energy with my
downward energy and when I neutralize
and even them the hand sticks to the
weest
we but even on that one my hand slipped
at some point cuz you freaked out and
you let the energy die you get it if
you're going full speed and let's go
back okay you're here and when you go
full speed that weapon came up do you
see that it didn't go like this it
didn't
go do you see do you understand so when
you go full speed it's one energy and
you see that now I can move it with one
energy I don't have to calculate for
your countering do do you get that did
you feel that okay I don't know if you
could see it but I could feel it and to
me I demonstrated it all right so just
as he did as much experience as he has
with feeling this even every time
someone feels it they freak the F out
and they'll freak out more when weapons
are involved okay so again I'll try to
make my point he had upward energy I
have downward energy stay there please
and I go ahead and adhere and when I
adhere I bring the Target that I want
the X closer to me so that I don't have
to over penetrate and I can cut the
wrist off as I demonstrated okay the
scaredy UK is going to just
kill their part of the
adhesion so I'll be they'll feel the
pressure of the sword and they kind of
drop it you don't even have to let go
you could just let it go to there you
get it so you feel it you drop it okay
but if you pay attention again while
that works at slow speed didn't pull him
in didn't do anything he feels quite a
lot when we go fast it goes into his
shoulders it goes into his shoulders
it'll pin his legs and I will still hit
the wrist and I demonstrated this in one
of the earlier videos
okay and most importantly he has no
counter and now we can't continue the
set okay what people have done with cha
Sensei forms are the following in my
opinion this person just touches this
like hits the stick and then he can pull
out and do something else meaning I'm
never really doing the move and so he
never really has to counter it okay and
that's totally different and when we get
to move five you're going to see how
radically different my form is and why
and the and why I do it that way is
because I have problems with I'm
supposed to do an attack and they're
supposed to counter it I'm not supposed
to just take turns all right so let's
get to that point and we're going to
stay slow so we can make this point all
right so I going one he goes boom and I
cut okay and we'll switch rolls cuz he
doesn't know this
part uh you got to go slow you can't
freak out cuz I got to be able to talk
do you understand and so as I'm talking
you can remain present without freaking
out okay all right so he goes I go one
two and he cuts my arm off that's what
he's going to do never bring the sword
over the way like that okay so you
you're not going to cut way across your
body like that keep the sword in the
center of your body so one two three and
he cuts don't bring the sword over there
keep it in the center of your body just
flick it do you get it okay so here we
go one two three and he cuts cut it all
right here's what most people do one two
three and they go this way and then they
see here
all right let's look at how would that
work I have problems with this because
his weapon is in the way of my ski if
you take for
example um pretend this is uh do shi shi
just do it on my head if I was going to
do Makia Tosh you see that I moved the
weapon out of the way and there's the C
cha Sensei forms do that all the time
dis place the weapon from the center
line then attack on the center line but
here on this movement the way most
people do it is they come over here the
sword is on the center line why would I
enter here makes no sense
okay but if you pay
attention he did a move he doesn't
really attack my wrist he over
penetrates and he doesn't doesn't really
capture my center and hence I can pull
out so we'll do it again I go he goes
one 2 3 and I can just pull out this way
but if he had the adhesion go a little
slow go a little slower one two boom he
pulls me in I wouldn't even be able to
do that movement you can see on video
move number four how fast that little
flick is okay you're not going to be
able to go in and out and even if you
could the sword is waiting for you there
on the ski okay so we have to counter
his weapon and the way we counter it is
not by disengaging from the ike adhesion
but using the IE adhesion okay so we
can't be a little scared to who is cuz
you're going to want to disengage and it
may look like it works at slow speed but
it will not work at fast speed okay all
right so here we go he goes one two
three go slower rele what I'm going to
do is maintain that contact I let him
pull me I maintain that contact and when
he comes back I'm going to bring this
all the way around to
here one two boom and free and
there
all I'm doing is when he hits it you're
going to have a circle on the ski and
in in every time you ski there's a
circle I'm just using that Circle and
I'm using the adhesion to stay on here
boom
I don't you want to film it from
different
angles one 2 3
4 at this speed you don't have to fall
you just move
back
see how close you can get so you can
start working on your
fear Bo boom tie
again no wait for the damn thing to come
up before you reach for it right
okay boom boom pop
boom too far away let's see if you can
figure out that
Jo take advantage of the so speed to
learn that you can take a blow from this
okay got it so I go one two three figure
it out
nope there you go we draw the J there we
go a lot of tension in your
body
that's where that attention doesn't work
let's go slower
slower
good withdraw the
J
slower slower
relax good H set this what I mean now
don't start getting used to getting hit
at this speed it's not going to hurt
you doesn't take that much tension to do
it and you want to do it on the draw
again I'm not going to coach your Joe
anymore I'm coaching the
bulen
do it differently but I'm trying to
correct I show the
mistake you see the
fear right there right there that's
where I want to
be you're okay
and
okay and uh let's get back to the job
now
slower slower and
relax one two I'm drawing it as I'm
making the
circle don't go like
this as you're draw lower place
why am I going why am I staying slower I
can't take it fast you can't take it
fast you have too much tension in your
body so we're slowing down so you can
Brave up so you can let go of the
tension do you understand so go slow and
release your tension as you're doing it
there's tension in your shoulders
already relax and settle into the
ground here we go breathe in lift the
here try it again slower W in you go pop
it's when I draw the weapon got it don't
be out there
painting one two
no boom it's when you
cut in okay try
it